[Music]
hey everybody this is gonna be my gifted
finale video it's really the last two
episodes they just aired them
back-to-back like it was a two-hour
finale but it really is two distinct
episodes so just be careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet but they're
teasing a little bit of x-men schism
they're teasing some utopia some Genosha
and obviously a whole bunch of Hellfire
Club magneto stuff but if you're finding
me for the first time there's a whole
bunch of comic book stuff that's getting
ready to drop so be sure to subscribe to
get everything
now they're obviously mostly x-men
Easter eggs going on in the gifted
series but I think a really good
comparison to make is the légion series
because that's a cable show this is a
network show in the general level of
mayhem that they let things get to you
have that big polaris magneto twist at
the end where she goes all Days of
Future past what a magneto is getting
ready to kill the President of the
United States and the big Sentinel
program which they referenced during the
episode I thought the writers did a lot
of hand-holding implying what the big
arcs of season 2 are going to be but I
think they just wanted to let you know
where everybody was going to be at and
it's all very logical like I believe
what's going on with Polaris in Andy's
character even though I find the child
actors on the show the least interesting
characters they do have the Fenris
ability but obviously now that they're
not with each other I think is basically
like Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver
breaking up they can't form Fenris
anymore but I do think the brother
versus sister story arc will be there
Magneto Professor Xavier of season 2 so
it'll be much more interesting for the
characters even if it's gonna cause a
major downgrade in their ability but
that twist at the end was pretty funny
where Pilar shows up and clearly is
recruiting for the Hellfire Club and
Andy's like sorry fam Darkseid has a
better gym I got to go with them they
have a way cooler dorm and the Stepford
cuckoos are mad hot so I'm gonna try and
get a piece of that so it will be funny
to see how Andy reacts to the separate
cuckoos and how they try to manipulate
him because they did remind you through
the episode they do have the ability to
control people's minds and when all
three of them are together the effect is
cumulative meaning they get even more
powerful that was the whole thing about
the Hound program about how Polaris was
more powerful because her baby gave her
the stacking bonus to her abilities
that's why she was able to take the
plane down from a great distance so it
all goes into that schism story arc
about how they'll be weaker
now that they're not together anymore
but because agent Turner quit mutant
services at the end I'm wondering if
they're just getting rid of that
organization as a main antagonist for
season 2 and it's going to be more
Hellfire Club versus Trask industries
versus the underground because very
clearly they're setting it up as a
Hellfire Club versus the underground but
the real villain of the series right now
is dr. Campbell and he might wind up
crawling away from that wreckage and
become a more recognizable villain
because it took him a while to manifest
in the series like first he was just a
really interesting scientist that wanted
some help from mutant services then he
became more pushy then he became more of
a legit Trask figure from Days of Future
past so you probably picked up on a lot
of the Days of Future past Easter eggs
some of them were plot based like when
they referenced the mechanical sentinels
going haywire they were talking about
the big blowup with Magneto so just to
clarify the timeline when they say
magneto is Polaris's father and they
talk about Brotherhood of mutants
seeding money to the Hellfire Club
they're talking mostly about Fassbender
era
magneto but they played a little fast
and loose with continuity so a lot of
the Easter eggs will also be for classic
Bryan Singer x-men may we never mention
his name again but they did mention the
Brotherhood of mutants several times
they kept talking about the 715 event
which was also the mysterious event that
led to the disappearance of the
Brotherhood characters as well as the
x-men but it sounds like an
extinction-level M Day event so that
might be what they're referencing from
the comics just something that
completely wiped out both big groups in
one fell swoop it all the stuff that's
happening right now is the aftermath
like there are still mutants in the
world but all the really big omega-level
mutant disappeared in a wink it's more
of a storytelling device that the
writers are using to explain why magneto
isn't flying around doing all these
things and why Professor Xavier and the
x-men don't show up every week they talk
about an organization called humanity
today that's an Easter Egg for Humanity
now which is an organization that Trask
is behind in the comics they call back
to the purifiers again obviously the
Brotherhood the Blanc used to work with
they keep talking about Otto's research
and eliminating the X gene during the
Logan movie they did that with food
additives like they actually suppress
the X gene in new fetuses from
expressing by just putting it
all the food so like high fructose corn
syrup processed foods so they also talk
about the Fenris twins trying to create
a place for immunes a special place
that's a reference to Genosha or even
utopia which are both magneto places but
Genosha is actually I think going to be
used during the Dark Phoenix movie it's
not just a special place that magneto
creates for mutants like the utopia
asteroid it's actually a place that used
to be more of a prison colony for
mutants that magneto later took over
with a coup and had the government turn
it over to him then he converted it to a
safe haven for mutants so it would be
like turning a concentration camp into a
refuge there was a pretty cool Chris
Claremont character that showed up at
the beginning of episode 13 when Polaris
is in the mental hospital and she's
twirling around that piece of Magneto's
costume a friend of my mother's gave
this to me a long time ago she reveals
herself as a mutant she has that red
hand she's not a devil her name is
actually Evangeline Whedon she can turn
into a dragon
so his her just revealing her dragon
itself to Polaris it actually be pretty
badass to see what she looks like when
she's full-on turn but they also
referenced someone called Madeline
Richmond there's a Deborah Richmond
during the animated series that's
responsible for creating x-23 there's
also Madeline Pryor who's a clone of
Jean Grey so I think they're just
weaking at her when they talk about a
Madeline but I think the Madeline Rist
min is just a combination of a couple
different characters like there's a
Matthew risk man who is one of the
purifiers in an ally of Strykers in the
comics so they're just combining a bunch
of different things but I think it was
pretty obvious in episode 12 that they
were setting up the Hellfire Club is a
major season 2 location like look at
this awesome house we have all these
awesome things for people to live in
places to be so because Polaris is now
full-blown Hellfire Club we're probably
gonna get a lot of scenes there during
season 2 but there's a big question
about what they're gonna do with the
underground but that was also kind of
the reason for destroying the old base -
like they let it go up in a blink of
light when they use their Fenris force
but the production probably didn't want
to continue paying for that location and
what better way to move everyone to a
new location and a new base that looks
different than by destroying the old
base just letting you know we're not
going to be coming back here any time
soon but the only other confirmations
that they made about season 2
terms of storylines or what's going on
with characters is that the Stepford
cuckoos have been upgraded to series
regular so they're gonna be more of a
stand-in villain next to dr. Campbell if
he crawls out of that wreckage I think
that's probably the biggest reason why
hardcore comic book fans didn't support
the show quite as much usually that's
what happens is when they want to make a
show for major Network they try to go
relatively comic book light or a wade
into the mythology so we can feel like
it moves really slow but as a show it
actually worked pretty well I think he
just moved a little too slow like they
just need to pick up the pace and get a
little more comic book II and that's
what they're doing with this Hellfire
Club arc that was the big paradigm shift
with The Stepford cuckoos reveal like oh
wow we're not just one person were three
people and a really big comic book
character at that as far as I know they
intend to premiere in the fall just like
a normal television show was so there's
not gonna be any major delay there been
a lot of big television shows that have
had major delays this past season most
network shows don't experience that
they're on a relatively predictable
schedule but what will happen is is
there's a whole bunch of comic book TV
that's coming back tonight they just did
a bunch of Legion of super-heroes stuff
on Supergirl so I'll try to get a video
out for that stuff tomorrow morning but
just leave all your requests in the
comments below while you wait for
everything click here for brand new
flash and click here for brand new
Avengers infinity war thank you so much
for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]